[Music]
alignment and structure as it relates to
iida so alignment structure is simply
those two things alignment is my ability
to align my body correctly with the
ground in order to receive Force so if
mik were to grab me roughly marote and
push into me I can align from my foot
through my hip through my spine into my
shoulder out my hand and into Mike so
Mike's pushing really hard this is not a
drink if you if I move my hand you can
see Mike's actually pushing very hard
but what I'm doing is aligning myself so
mik's essentially pushing through my
bones into the ground it' be no
different if you stuck a stick in the
ground and push into the ground okay so
that's a nice example of alignment this
can be done on a slightly more advanced
level if I were to sit on the ground and
M could to push on my head I simply
align from my head through my neck
through my spine my butt into the ground
so M essentially just pushing into the
ground right here Mike's trying very
hard as you can see to push me over but
he can't because I'm aligned right it's
just simply the structure of my body
aligning into mik uh so that could be
done with a stick or anything it's just
I'm aligning my body properly now
there's another trick I can use in
structure if M were to push on my
shoulders and I were to Simply Touch
under his shoulders as he pushes he push
as hard as he wants but because my hands
are touching here what's happening is
and you see M's pushing very hard uh
what's happening is Mike's pushing into
himself my energy is being redirected
into his hands so our structure becomes
one so when he pushes he's pushing into
his own structure by trying to push me
over I can also do this on one foot if
Mike were to come and and here I stand
on one foot mik goes to push me over I'm
simply standing under see oh M can't
push me over because I have my hand
right under his arm like this as he's
pushing he can't get me over I'm on one
foot okay so I'm using structure in that
situation to keep his force from
toppling me over I'm becoming one
structure with him or I can simply align
myself from aligning through the ground
through my body and into my partner
alignment and structure